in your nintendo ad i know it says like
this is what you do on a rainy day
but i think what you guys really mean is
like this is what you do every day
of this past year like this is all of us
just playing all the nintendo all the
time
yeah yeah yeah yeah i think the rainy
day is a metaphor
for kind of a the global pandemic
that we're living in and um
yeah i mean the nintendo switch has
served
many purposes for me over these like
long
long long days at home because it's it's
so versatile and it offers so many
different
options from just pure escapism to
actual
getting up off the couch which is like a
completely new concept
for me um and like moving your bot
around
so it's been it's been really um
a real plus i love that there's the
section of the video where like your mom
completely schools you in
classic board games and stuff like this
is that true to life is she
a competitive person you know i think
my mom actually had a bit of a hard time
with that because she's not
a competitive person at all so she
really had to like
we we rehearsed the night before she
really had to brush up on her acting
chops
to to like really find that competitive
uh that competitive attack at me and i
think actually
even some of the producers were throwing
kind of wild lines at her
that were getting more aggressive and
competitive and my mom just had to be
like
oh no i i don't think i i don't think
i'd say that but she does love
the ability to actually see me is a big
plus for her
yeah so i think that that was that was
the appeal for her
in the uh in the in the game
i know for a lot of us just playing
video games online has been a way for
people to just stay in touch with their
friends just because it's
i mean you're not doing it right you're
not doing it any other way like this is
how we're gonna do it has that been
something that you found true for
yourself i mean you said this
served so many purposes for you the
switch itself has like online gaming
been something that's helped you through
oh 100 i think that any
any excuse to you know call up a friend
and
and rope them into your you know lonely
room that you've been
in for the last week or so um
yeah and you know friday nights aren't
what they used to be
saturday nights aren't what they used to
be so um
you know the ability to open a bottle of
wine
and invite invite a friend over to do
like just dance 2020 and flail around
and embarrass yourself
it's um it's been it really has made me
look forward to
two weekends what does someone's
pick for mario kart character like the
person that they made in mario kart what
does that say about them
like if you're toad what does that say
about you okay this is
i think this is a very deep question
which i don't know
because my
my uh interest in picking my mario kart
characters is purely aesthetic on how
cute
the character is and i know that that's
not wise i know that you know
yoshi and toad are not the strongest and
they're not the fastest
but god they're adorable um
i don't know i feel like they're you
know we could sit down on a therapist
couch and really get into it
what do you what are yours what are your
faves i mean i
i like going with shy guy because
versatile you know like i was i had a
match last night
and i was wearing orange so i was like
obviously i'm going to pick shy guy
because he can wear orange
so why not and then there was a point
where i was like you're into it
right it's all about yeah it's
accessorizing
okay and i was like i was like wait why
did i pick this combination because i'm
terrible right now like i'm so slow but
you know you got to stick with it you
got to do it
they feel you we're so you and i are
both into aesthetics that's what
that's cool for sure okay for better or
worse yeah
um i remember being a kid not knowing a
lot of girls that were gamers
and you know like my sister's older than
me and she wasn't like into it
but now it's so different my daughter's
seven and i kid you not like she could
school me in mario kart it's not
something that i admit easily but it's
true
very very brave of you thank you yes
well but the couch right the couch
but like do you think that's do you see
that as something that's changed a lot
or like were you into games a lot as a
kid
and maybe it wasn't something that you
could admit like i
don't know um i i wasn't
i've just kind of like come into it in
the last couple of years
um i i don't know if it's that i wasn't
allowed
to game i think it just wasn't really in
like in the sphere of my
uh my household but i know my cousins
i was my cousins both boys and girls did
have nintendo and so i was
so thirsty whenever i got to go and have
a sleepover at my cousin's house i was
just i was
there and we were nintendo all the time
like
into the wee hours of the morning um but
i have
noticed so many more it was kind of a
guy thing for some reason like a boy
thing
um but so many more girls playing
seeing them you know walking around
with their devices like just and i know
from the way that their hands are moving
that they're professionals
um so it is it's really cool to see that
it has become
very much uh everyone's everyone's thing
that was and the commercial that's
actually one thing that i noticed right
away
is that you're not going like this
because in every like movie or tv show
before when they would show someone
playing a video game
it was literally them playing like this
like hitting all the things at the exact
same time
and yes she plays because she's playing
it the right way
i don't know this well it's i've grown
i've really evolved because when i was
younger i really was just a button
masher
because i didn't have it at home and so
i would just mash the buttons and then
just end up like
bashing into walls over and over again
and getting increasingly
frustrated but i've come a long way yes
we can see that
one thing that's really fun fun about
going into the comments for that video
is how many people are going hey that's
a little bit of lexus
oh it's a little bit alexis like that's
that's like the cultural touchstone for
people that are watching it and it's
amazing because number one the show is
absolutely incredible
number two that song is
the number one song of i don't know the
last five years i think
what do you remember or what can you
tell us about like sitting down and
writing that song uh with your husband
well uh i mean so the the
song came up in the episode when we were
doing a table read i saw
alexis sings a little bit alexis and i
think because
noah reed had done such a beautiful job
doing simply the best the season before
i was like all right this is my time to
shine not really
realizing that noah is a musician and i
am very much not a musician
so so dan very
um you know i was very fortunate that
dan
agreed to let me do it and so yeah i sat
down with two of my
best buds who are musicians so they
really saved me in that sense and we uh
i wrote most of the lyrics and they did
all the
the technical complicated you know beeps
and
boops and producing events
and we all we all secretly wanted to
make a song that was
a banger but we knew it had to be funny
and but deep down we were like we really
want this to be
good so we just kind of posted up in the
studio for a few days
and came out with a little bit
and i don't think we realized
to what level that the song would
make it like like it was it's really
it's become
quite a quite a thing people play it in
clubs like it's it's wild it's truly
wild
i'm just i'm just trying to get a visual
in my head of like
you coming up with the words like you
said you you secretly wanted to be a
banger but at what
how often are you sitting there going
like holding in your laughter or like
having to stop because you're like
we know this is hilarious or someone in
your crew being like do you know how
ridiculous that is
like is that is was that the process or
were you seriously like comedy
i'm 100 like serious about making this
work
um it was it was a bit of both i think
i think you kind of had to turn off the
like
fact that that the lyrics are so
ridiculous in order to get them down but
then
yeah there were some moments in the like
um
i had a real a real time with
everybody's got a horse
that was a hard that was a really hard
one to get out but we listened to so
much um we listened to paris hilton
stuff we listened to
brittany obviously and those songs
as much as they're the best songs
they're also
very ridiculous so we did we did
definitely borrow a bunch of the uh
the melodies and also the humor of these
serious songs that were out there in the
world that's awesome
um you guys did your emmy like pandemic
emmy party the right way a fantastic
thing to see to be able to see
you know you guys together with the
golden globe nominations coming out soon
uh do you have any plans to
redo it up like any any idea of how you
guys might celebrate
oh gosh i think well things just kind of
all fell into place for the emmys so
many of us were
already in toronto um and we had the
ability to
test and distance and get this beautiful
party while dan arranged this beautiful
um party for us
but now we're kind of spread out i'm in
boston now
noah's in new mexico dan's in toronto
emily's
god knows where um so we're all kind of
spread out over the over the map um so i
i don't know what we're gonna do i feel
like i feel like we're gonna end up
doing what a bunch of us thought we were
gonna do for the emmys which is just be
on our couch um in
sweat clothes
that's that's what i'm anticipating for
me anyway nice
yeah playing switch in between
categories yeah commercial breaks yeah
yeah
have you um have you talked to dan about
his
hosting slot on snl like has it has told
you about
what he might be doing um no no no no
all i know is that um
he's he goes through moments of because
i first texted him like
i am so nervous for you i think that
that was my first which probably wasn't
very helpful at all
um but i was like i'm just so riddled
with nerves for you and so he just
all he said is that he's going through
very very kind of eerily calm
moments and then just being walloped
with nerves and it's just
it's just going back and forth between
those two extreme
things so i'm so stoked to watch i i'm
i already have plans to get together and
open a bottle of wine and watch him do
his thing i think we're all
so excited for that how traditionally
how does he do with like
i guess those i assume he's really good
at those high pressure situations
yeah he's someone that i'm very jealous
of because he you know he talks a big
talk about
being so nervous and you know
anticipating just doing a terrible job
and messing up but
literally every time he comes through in
a way that
um you know makes my jaw drop and you
would never know
if he is being truthful about these
nerves um
you would never know because he's able
to be able to pull it off
so beautifully so but we'll see we'll
see
what happens you know i'm sure it'll be
amazing
um i want to talk about your new series
and i don't know if i'm allowed to say
the title of it
like if you i mean i might get in
trouble if i say the full title of it
i mean should we just both say it at the
same time so we both get in trouble or
like like should we do the like thing
where we sort of bleep out a thing
or like what if like what do you think
i actually i hate bleeps i just go for
it
yeah do you want to do it three yeah
three two one
kevin kevin can i
you wait you i feel like you left me
hanging there no you left me hanging on
one head
it's is it the zoom pro is it the thing
it might be the zoom left us hanging
yeah let's not turn each other no no no
so what tell us all about it this is
like a dark comedy what's happening
yeah i'm so i'm so so excited about it
it's um it's a dark comedy
it's uh it's an amc hour long
and it's so it's basically about you
know how
we have the sitcom that we're so used to
of this
usually about a guy and uh his
beer drinking friends and loves sports
and there's always the
wife who kind of serves him sandwiches
and is the butt of a bunch of jokes
um this show that i'm in
uh is from the perspective of the sitcom
wife
and it follows her while her husband is
doing whatever
idiotic stuff he's doing it follows her
into
um a very secret world that she's living
a secret life that she's living while
the cameras aren't
on um and what's really cool about it is
that it goes back and forth between
multicam so the classic sitcom world
with canned laughter and
the stage and the lighting but when
she's by herself
it's very gritty very beautiful single
cam
um and yeah i'm so proud of it i just
got to see
a couple of cuts the other day and it's
it's
really good if i do say something how
far along are you in it
uh we so we shot the first four episodes
before christmas and we just got back
and we're shooting another four
um right now and we wrapped mid-march
so that's awesome well because every
sitcom was like the doofusey dude
married to this
like super smart beautiful woman but you
that's true like you never see
what she's up to when she's not there
going what are you doing like that sort
of thing
and yeah yeah and it's also um you know
a really interesting kind of
study in what we are told
to laugh at and what we are told to to
find
what you know what we're told to find
funny
um because if you remove the laugh track
a lot of the things that are being said
are very derogatory
very sexist very inappropriate very
sometimes racist sometimes homophobic
um but there's a you know canned
laughter over top that kind of
glazes all of that over um so it's kind
of
it's taking a pulling that back and
really asking like what
what are we doing here what are we
finding funny and and uh
who is this woman when she's not just
being a wife
right on very cool so much to be excited
about this has been a lot of fun thank
you so much for doing this with us thank
you it's a pleasure
you